[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marieta Slomka guten Abend was
war das für ein Wochenende auch Europas
Regierungen sind noch damit beschäftigt
sich auf die Ereignisse in Russland
einen Rhein zu machen wobei bei den
Europäern erschwerend hinzukommen dass
sie die Wagner Meuterei offenbar
überhaupt nicht kommen sahen während die
amerikanischen Dienste laut US-Medien
das Weiße Haus frühzeitig vorwarten dass
sich da etwas anbahnt darüber habe ich
vorhin auch mit
Bundesverteidigungsminister Pistorius
gesprochen wie schätzt er diese Vorgänge
und die jetzige Lage in Russland ein
Pistorius selbst sorgte heute auch noch
für eine Überraschung als er die
dauerhafte Verlegung deutscher Soldaten
nach Litauen ankündigte davon und vom
Treffen der EU-Außenminister berichtet
Florian neu an
im kleinen klappt das in Europa heute
gut mit dem Multitasking unterschreiben
Glocke läuten alles parallel es ist
vielleicht das Bild für diesen Tag an
dem Europa mal wieder alles zugleich
hinkriegen muss sich einen reinmachen
auf russische Machtkämpfe Osteuropäer
beruhigen und nebenbei die Ukraine
unterstützen geht das sich an den Reim
zu machen ist schon schwierig genug die
Ereignisse in Russland haben Europa kalt
erwischt am Montag danach gibt es zwei
Deutungen die hoffnungsvolle erzählt von
Rissen im russischen System
das Putin mit der wagnertruppe
geschaffen hat beißt ihn nun selbst das
politische System Russlands zeigt seine
Schwächen
ist die andere Deutung ist deutlich
sorgenvoller findet aber nicht weniger
Zustimmung
das wäre absolut
gefährlich für Europa wenn so ein das
größte Land der Welt mit den meisten
Atomwaffen der Welt wenn das
zerbröckeln würde und dann sind da die
Länder im Osten Europas mit direkter
Grenze zu Russland und Belarus Länder
wie Litauen die sich vor russischen
Panzern fürchten
es hat nur einen halben Tag gedauert um
so viele Truppen bis 200 km vor Moskau
marschieren zu lassen wie schnell
könnten sie danach Belarus an unsere
Grenze marschieren wir bitten unsere
Verbündeten eindringlich genau auf
unsere Situation zu schauen
was der litauische Außenminister da
offenbar noch nicht ahnt dass nur wenig
später in Litauen selbst der deutsche
Verteidigungsminister etwas ankündigt
deutschland ist bereit dauerhaft eine
robuste Brigade in Litauen zu
stationieren also 4000 Soldaten +
Familien das Deutschland bisher nicht
klar zugesagt hatte bis sie Litauen sind
wird es dauern aber allein die Nachricht
sendet ein starkes Signal was sie zurück
in Luxemburg bei den Außenministern auch
senden wollen Richtung Ukraine der
zugeschaltete ukrainische Außenminister
hört zwar dass die EU die Militärhilfe
um 3,5 Milliarden Euro erhöht aber auch
dass die halbe Milliarde die daraus an
die Ukraine fließen soll blockiert wird
von Ungarn
es tut mir wirklich leid dass diese
Tranche noch immer nicht geeint ist wir
werden daran arbeiten mit Ungarn und der
Ukraine diese bedauerliche Situation zu
lösen
Multitasking das menschliche Gehirn sagt
man könne sich nur auf eine Sache
konzentrieren in der internationalen
Politik ist das leider keine Option
ja und zur verarbeiten gibt es in der
Tat eine ganze Menge nicht nur dass da
eine Art Privatarmee auf Moskau zu
marschierte praktisch unbehelligt
bemerkenswert ist auch dass sie Anführer
der berüchtigte prigoshi zuvor in einem
Video quasi sämtlichen Behauptungen
Putins widersprach warum Russland Krieg
gegen die Ukraine führt dass in der
Ukraine Nazis regierten das von der
Ukraine eine Bedrohung für Russland
Sicherheit ausgegangen sei alles Lügen
so rigoshi wo er sich derzeit aufhält
ist und bekannt wie lange noch im Leben
bleibt auch aber noch ist der offenbar
lebendig genug um sich heute wieder zu
Wort zu melden und auf Vladimir Putin
hat sich erneut im Fernsehen gezeigt
Tenor alles im Griff kein Grund zur
Besorgnis berichtet
zur Stunde äußert sich Putin zur Lage in
Russland die wagner-mitglieder die
Patrioten sind werden ihren Dienst in
anderen Strukturen fortsetzen können
diejenigen die das nicht wollen können
nach Belarus gehen die Vorgänge vom
Wochenende seien Verrat an Russland und
am russischen Volk davon ziemlich
unbeeindruckt zeigen sich die Menschen
heute in der russischen Hauptstadt
weniger als zwei Tage nachdem die Wagner
Söldner Richtung Moskau marschiert waren
alles ist schon vorbei genug davon alles
wird gut wenn man seinen Verstand
einschaltet es ist wie in der Familie es
rutscht vielleicht einmal die Hand aus
aber danach beruhigen sich alle wieder
ich denke es werden Veränderungen kommen
Radikale und gezielte das wird natürlich
passieren denn auf all das muss man
irgendwie reagieren wenn man es nicht
tut dann könnte es wieder passieren
heute sind die Anti terror-vorkehrungen
aufgehoben worden das System Putin
scheint zu wanken aber ist das der
Anfang vom Ende
der putin ist in seiner Macht natürlich
angezählt das muss man sagen sein
Prestige erschüttert inwieweit das
unmittelbare Konsequenzen haben wird da
wäre ich erst skeptisch auch Moskau aus
Führung bemüht sich um Normalität das
russische Verteidigungsministerium
veröffentlicht Aufnahmen von
Verteidigungsminister scheugu bei einem
Truppenbesuch in der Ukraine er lobte
den Einsatz der russischen Streitkräfte
wie aktuell und wahrheitsgetreu die
Aufnahmen sind lässt sich nicht
feststellen Experten haben allerdings
Zweifel
mit so vielen Räumlichkeiten ich denke
das ist in Russland also ich halte das
eher für inszeniert
die Botschafter hinter Stärke und
Kontrolle demonstrieren dazu erscheinen
zahlreiche Videos die die russischen
Truppen bei erfolgreichen kämpfen in der
Ukraine zeigen sollen gleichzeitig zeigt
die Ukraine Vorstöße unter anderem in
bachmut Wahrheitsgehalt auf beiden
Seiten nicht überprüfbar der ukrainische
Präsident selenski zeigt sich
überraschend bei einem frontbesuch in
der östlichen teilweise von Russland
besetzten Region dornies die Lage
scheint unverändert trotz der
ungewöhnlichen Ereignisse vom Wochenende
und dann bleibt da noch die große Frage
nach gregorchin am frühen Abend meldet
er sich mit einer audiobo Botschaft
wir hielten in dem Moment an als das
erste Kommando zu unserer Abwehr dass
ich 200 km vor Moskau befand seine
Artillerie aufstellte da war
offensichtlich dass viel Blut vergossen
werden würde wir waren der Meinung dass
wir ausreichend gezeigt haben was wir
vorhatten wir sind dort hingegangen um
unseren Protest zu demonstrieren und
nicht um die Staatsmacht im Land zu
stürzen
die wagnertruppen haben Rostov
inzwischen verlassen wo sich bregorchin
derzeit aufhält ist unklar
Bundesverteidigungsminister ist uns
zugeschaltet guten Abend Herr Pistorius
guten Abend Frau slamka das ist ja ein
ziemlich wildes Wochenende was wir alle
hinter uns haben darum zunächst die
Frage wie sieht diese Situation
einschätzen also mehrheitlich hört man
ja auch aus anderen NATO-Ländern das war
eine reale Meuterei und es hat dadurch
gezeigt dass es Risse im Machtsystem von
Wladimir Putin gibt würden sie diese
Einschätzung teilen
soweit man das von außen beurteilen kann
würde ich diese Einschätzung teilen da
liegt einiges im Argen um es vorsichtig
zu formulieren und zur Stabilität hat
der Vorgang mit Sicherheit nicht
beigetragen
wer denn dann auch der Zeitpunkt nicht
spätestens jetzt gekommen dass ich die
NATO dass ich die Europäer auch auf die
Möglichkeit vorbereiten dass die
Russische Föderation implodiert
ich denke das werden die Außenpolitiker
schon tun und wir als
Verteidigungspolitiker beschäftigen uns
ja permanent mit der Sicherheitslage
insgesamt aber bislang gibt es keine
Anzeichen dafür auf bestimmte Dinge mehr
vorbereitet zu sein als vorher aber wir
haben ein sehr wachsames Auge darauf
denn die Entwicklung ist durchaus ja
beunruhigend
Anzeichen also für den den Marsch von
prigos hin Richtung Moskau hat man
offenbar in Europa und in Berlin auch
keine Anzeichen gesehen anders als die
amerikanischen Geheimdienste die da
offenbar ich sag mal etwas schärfere
Augen haben
das weiß ich ehrlich gesagt nicht wäre
jetzt hinterher was gewusst haben will
oder tatsächlich gewusst hat das ändert
aber auch nichts wir müssen mit der
Situation in Russland so umgehen wie sie
sich ergibt und das ist sehr fragil sehr
volatil die verschiedenen Gruppen
untereinander dass die Konflikte sich
seit einiger Zeit angebahnt haben war ja
sichtbar dass das dann so plötzlich
istkaliert ja das ist so entscheidend
ist jetzt was passiert anschließend in
Russland welche Gerüchte bestätigen sich
und welche nicht
haben Sie irgendwelche Vorstellungen wie
es dort jetzt eventuell weitergehen
könnte man weiß im Moment ja noch nicht
mal wo sich aufhält ist der jetzt nach
Belarus so gehen sie davon aus
darüber gibt es mindestens drei oder
vier verschiedene Gerüchte oder Meldung
von daher würde ich mich daran gar nicht
beteiligen
entscheidend ist dass wir gucken wie ist
die militärische Entwicklung was
passiert an den in den sensiblen
Bereichen aber eine Prognose darüber wie
sich das weiterentwickelt traue ich mir
ehrlich gesagt zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt
nicht zu dann haben sie ihren Litauen
heute eine Militärübung eine gemeinsame
der deutschen unterle Litauer beobachtet
die relativ nah an der Grenze zu Belarus
ist die Litauer befürchten dass von dort
jetzt neue Gefahren drohen wie sehen Sie
das
das hängt eben davon ab ob die Meldungen
stimmen oder ob es bloße gerüchtet sehen
wo briochien tatsächlich ist mit seinen
Truppen aber selbst wenn er in Belarus
wäre müsste das nicht zwangsläufig eine
Bedrohung bedeuten sondern könnte wieder
mal ein ganz anderen Hintergrund haben
also auch da gilt wir bewegen uns im
Reich der Spekulation entscheidend ist
aber dass ich natürlich die baltischen
Staaten und allen voran Litauen hier
große Sorgen machen die Situation ist
ohnehin angespannt und gerade litauen
ist besonders exponiert von daher ist es
dann auch gut das zufällig heute wie ihr
hier sind und diese Übung stattfindet um
deutlich zu machen Deutschland die NATO
stehen zu unseren Alliierten hier an der
ostfranke haben ja auch schon lange zu
verstehen gegeben dass sie das nicht gut
finden das deutsche Soldaten nur
zeitweise bei ihnen im Land stationiert
sind jetzt haben sie nachgegeben und
gesagt ja wir werden 4.000 deutsche
Soldaten dauerhaft nach Litauen
verbringen da dürfte einigen in der
Bundeswehr die Kinder darunter geklappt
sein damit hat er auch niemand gerechnet
ich weiß nicht ob da mit niemand
gerechnet hat der Bundeskanzler hat eine
ähnliche Zusage vor einem Jahr gegenüber
Litauen gemacht wir haben lange überlegt
wie und wann wir das bewerkstelligen
können und klar ist es gibt zwar
Voraussetzungen und dabei muss es leider
noch bleiben die erste Voraussetzung ist
das der sacreur also der Befehlshaber
der nato-generatori die militärische
Flexibilität behält die er braucht
entlang der Ostflanke er muss das
beurteilen welchen Wert das hat und was
dagegen spricht und die zweite
Voraussetzung ist dass die Infrastruktur
für eine Brigade in Litauen geschaffen
wird und das ist keine Banalität wir
reden über Unterkünfte über Kasern über
Übungsgelände dann wenn Familien dazu
kommen unsere Soldaten und Soldaten gibt
es auch um Kindergärten und Schulen das
baut man nicht mal eben so nebenbei in
einem Jahr auf und von der reden wir
über einen Prozess und darüber haben wir
heute gesprochen
dass sie da sehr fix sein werden die
sind ja sehr daran interessiert und wenn
ich sie eben richtig verstanden habe die
Bundeswehrsoldaten sollen dann also
dauerhaft auch mit ihren Familien nach
Litauen ja regelrecht umziehen richtig
und das ist ja das Wesen einer
dauerhaften Stationierung logischerweise
im Gegensatz zu einer rollierenden einer
rotierenden
Stationierung aber wie gesagt der
entscheidende Punkt ist jetzt dass die
Infrastruktur ist und dass der NATO ihr
Okay geben dafür dass die militärische
Flexibilität gewahrt ist weil das hat
die absolute Priorität und dem haben
sich alles stationierungsentscheidungen
der NATO Partner unterzuordnen aber die
Richtung ist klar haben Sie denn da
Zweifel oder vermuten sie dass eventuell
Flexibilität dann im Sack hör doch
wichtiger ist als eine dauerhafte
Stationierung in einem Ort
ich habe dafür keine konkreten
Anhaltspunkte aber es gibt durchaus
Gesichtspunkte die dafür sprechen
könnten aber das wird sich jetzt zeigen
dem will ich ausdrücklich nicht
vorgreifen aber selbst wenn das so wäre
würde das ja nicht bedeuten dass man gar
nichts macht also ich würde das jetzt
einfach mal offen lassen und warten wie
original plants dann diskutiert werden
und welche operational plant sich daraus
dann ergeben denn die sind am Ende
maßgebend aber noch mal zurück auf das
unberechenbare was wir auch in diesem
Krieg erleben wo man dann plötzlich ja
Dinge erlebt die man auch nicht für
möglich gehalten hätte die ukrainische
Seite waren ja sehr eindringlich davor
dass Russland einen Terroranschlag oder
Sabotage Akte am Atomkraftwerk in
saporicia das ist ja auch eine stark
umkämpfte Region ist ausübt wenn er
jetzt nicht der Zeitpunkt Putin dem
Kreml sehr klar Signale von Seiten des
Westens zu setzen was dann das für
Konsequenzen hätte um ihn davon
abzuschrecken
also erstens glaube ich nicht das Putin
sich abschrecken lässt in seiner Art
Entscheidung zu treffen von
irgendwelchen roten Linien die im Westen
aufgezeigt werden alle wissen eine
solche Maßnahmen solcher Schritt gegen
das Atomkraft wäre ein schweres
Kriegsverbrechen darüber gibt es keine
zwei Meinungen ob Putin sich davon
abhalten lässt wenn wir sagen wir finden
das gefährlich und verurteilen ihn dafür
wenn es tut das wage ich zu bezweifeln
deswegen kommt drauf an dass wir uns
geschlossen aufstellen und versuchen
aufzuklären was dort vor sich geht aber
er Pistole ist Putin hat sich ja
offenbar auch von den Amerikanern
beeindrucken lassen als die ihm mal
gesagt haben was so alles passieren
würde sollte er taktischen Nuklearwaffen
einsetzen also der Mann lässt sich ja
durchaus offenbar beeindrucken selbst
von einem Führer einer Privatarmee in
seinem eigenen Land
das ist ein ja machen sie einen Punkt
vor slomker das ist völlig richtig und
deswegen ist ja die Klarheit in der
Ansage auch notwendig aber sie können
versichert sein dass es dort klare
Ansagen gibt
danke für das Gespräch
sehr gerne
die Ukraine hatte ja auch länger davor
gewarnt dass Russland den karowka
Staudamm sprengen würde ungeachtet der
katastrophalen Folgen ähnlich
nachdrücklich waren Kiew vor einem
Anschlag auf das Kraftwerk in saporecia
Europas größtes Atomkraftwerk ist von
Russen besetzt und liegt direkt an der
südlichen Front zwar wurde es schon im
September letzten Jahres weitgehend
heruntergefahren Kühlung und Strom
braucht es trotzdem die Internationale
Atomenergiebehörde versucht sich immer
wieder ein Bild von der Lage zu machen
der Chef Raphael grossi ist auch mit der
russischen Seite in Kontakt darüber habe
ich heute Nachmittag mit ihm gesprochen
tja wie ist die Situation in saporis
hier am Atomkraftwerk darüber wollen wir
mit dem Chef der Internationalen
Atomenergiebehörde sprechen mit Raphael
grossi guten Abend
sie waren am Freitag in Kaliningrad und
haben mit den russischen Vertretern über
den Schutz des Atomkraftwerks gesprochen
danach hat man nicht so viel von ihnen
gehört können Sie uns ein paar mehr
Informationen über diese Gespräche geben
ja ich bin nach Kaliningrad Gefahren am
Freitag
das war ein Nachfassen zu meinem Besuch
im in der Nuklearanlage zum dritten Mal
schon da wir Sie vielleicht wissen
insgesamt war ich acht Mal in der
Ukraine aber dreimal beim AKW in
saporicia
und ich hatte vor
nach meiner letzten Präsentation vom
Sicherheitsrat der Vereinten Nationen
dort noch einmal vorbei zu schauen
destruction aber danach gab es eben
diesen Fall der Zerstörung des Staudamms
des kachows
zu einer ganz neuen Situation geführt
die ukrainische Seite Präsident selenski
warnt ja dass die Russen auch den
kühlteich des Atomkraftwerks vermiet
hätten dass sie einen anschlagplan sie
haben damals als die vorletzte Woche in
saporissia war gesagt sie selbst hätten
dort keine Minen gesehen aber ja ich
meine man würde sie ihn vermutlich auch
nicht zeigen
nun ich bin durch dieses Gelände
durchgelaufen und ich habe da keine
Minen selber gesehen
[Musik]
natürlich kenne ich nicht die
Nachrichten Berichte über die der
Präsident gesprochen hat
ich hatte vorher ein langes Treffen mit
Präsident sensky ich bin ja bevor ich in
den Süden gefahren bin in Kiew gewesen
habe mit ihm gesprochen und dann bin ich
in dieser Region Gefahren
über die Front hinweg
aber wir und ein Team wir haben keine
Minen gesehen und wir haben
gesagt dass es durchaus in der Umgebung
der Anlage Minen gibt die die russischen
Streitkräfte als Teil der
Verteidigungsanlagen beschrieben haben
nachdem es einige Versuche gegeben hätte
das AKW wieder im Besitz zu nehmen
die Kühlwasser Teiche angeht da haben
wir nichts gesehen welche Folgen hätte
es denn wenn es eine Sabotage oder gar
keine Explosionen dieses Kraftwerks gäbe
die EA hat ja ein permanentes Team ist
ein technisches Team von Inspektoren und
von Sicherheitsexperten
wie sie die
besuchen verschiedene Teile der Anlage
und wir glauben dass deren Gegenwart
wenn auch nicht eine absolute
Abschreckung ist durch sie doch eine
gewisse Abschreckung und wir versuchen
zu verstehen wie die Situation aussieht
und die Völkergemeinschaft sofort
informiert wenn da etwas passieren wird
wir haben als sie natürlich nicht die
Fähigkeiten einer nukleären Polizei muss
mal einfach auszudrücken aber wir sind
da sehr aktiv und wir sind auch sehr
wachsam gegenüber dem was ich tut beim
AKW und zwar 24 Stunden am Tag sieben
Tage die Woche sagt der Chef der
Internationalen Atomenergiebehörde
Raphael groß ich danke sehr für das
Gespräch
das Interview haben wir etwas eingekürzt
sie können es in ganzer Länge online
abrufen und so weit jetzt erstmal unser
Blick heute auf die Lage in Russland und
der Ukraine mit Nachrichten aus
Deutschland geht es jetzt bei dir
erstmal weiter Heinz ja nach der Wahl
des bundesweit ersten AFD Landrats in
Sonneberg in Thüringen gab es heute
weitere Reaktionen der Präsident ist
Zentralrats der Juden Schuster nannte
das Ergebnis an den Dammbruch der
Vorsitzende der türkischen Gemeinde in
Deutschland verfolu meinte die Gefahr
sei größer als manche es wahrnehmen
würden in der Bundespolitik die Frage
nach den Ursachen und auch eigenen
Fehlern die Ampel hat ihre Politik in
letzter Zeit zu wenig erklärt nicht gut
organisiert zum Beispiel beim
heizungsgesetz wir müssen jetzt
durchstarten unsere Konzepte für die
Modernisierung des Landes eben auch
voranbringen wenn Sie die Bevölkerung
verlieren auf dem Weg den sie mit einer
solchen Transformation gehen wollen und
genau das ist jetzt eingetreten dann
dürfen sie sich über solche
Wahlergebnisse nicht wundern
Deutschland Frankreich und Italien
wollen bei wichtigen Rohstoffen wie
Lithium oder selten Erde Metallen enger
zusammenarbeiten
Wirtschaftsminister Harburg sprach nach
einem Treffen mit seinen Kollegen in
Berlin von einem Beitrag für mehr
Wirtschaft Sicherheit Europa ist bei
vielen Rohstoffen stark abhängig von
China und will das zügig ändern
Bundesgesundheitsminister Lauterbach hat
neue schutzangebote gegen Hitzewellen
angekündigt ihr berät heute über einen
nationalen hitzeschutzplan mit
Vertretern der Pflegebranche mit Ärzten
Kommunen und weiteren Experten als
erstes Angebot ist ein Portal online
gegangen mit Informationen für Kommunen
etwa zur Weitergabe von hitzewarnungen
und zur Vorsorge in sensiblen
Einrichtungen wie Pflegeheimen
Jugendämter in Deutschland haben im
vergangenen Jahr deutlich mehr Kinder
und Jugendliche zu deren Schutz
vorübergehenden Obhut genommen als im
Jahr davor nämlich
66.400 zu der Statistische Bundesamt 40%
mehr als 2021
Hauptgrund für den Anstieg mehr
unbegleitete einreisen Minderjähriger
etwa aus Afghanistan oder Syrien was
auch der häufigste Anlass für in
obhutnahmen war gefolgt von
Überforderung der Eltern und Anzeichen
für Vernachlässigung oder körperlicher
Misshandlung
der Bundesgerichtshof hat heute eine
Entscheidung getroffen mit der sich für
Betroffene Dieselfahrer die Chancen auf
Schadenersatzforderungen erhöhen könnten
dabei geht es um die sogenannte
thermofenstertechnik die Musterfälle
betreffen Audi Volkswagen und Mercedes
auf die Gerichte dürfte nun eine neue
Klagewelle zu rollen die Hintergründe
erklärt Jan Henrich
es ist der Bundesgerichtshof der
entscheiden musste ein vorläufiger
Höhepunkt nach jahrelangem Streit um den
Diesel drei Verfahren hatten die
Richterinnen und Richter in Karlsruhe
ausgewählt um einen Grundsatzurteil zu
sprechen eine Entscheidung auf die viele
dieselkäufer lange gewartet haben so wie
urgüzel gabacs 2017 kaufte einen
Mercedes Diesel C220 mit Euro 6 Norm was
er nicht ahnt mercedes hat in dem
Fahrzeug wie viele andere Autobauer auch
eine Motorsteuerung eingebaut die bei
kühleren Temperaturen die Abgasreinigung
reduziert oder sogar ganz abschaltet ein
sogenanntes Thermofenster
weil ich habe auch fünf Jahre lang meine
Ratten bezahlt ohne wenn und aber ob ich
das hatte oder nicht weil das war nicht
fair von denen das sind Weltkonzern wie
Mercedes dass sie sich sowas
sind Fazit des obersten Zivilgerichts ja
diese Kunden haben ein Recht auf
Schadensersatz wenn illegale
abschalteinrichtungen in ihren
Fahrzeugen verbaut sind und das gilt
auch wenn die Autobauer nur fahrlässig
gehandelt haben
dem einzelnen Käufer ist daher stets und
ohne dass das vorhanden sein eines
Schadens als solches mittels eine
sachverständige Gutachtens zu klären
wäre oder durch ein
Sachverständigengutachten in Frage
gestellt werden könnte
ein Schadenersatz in Höhe von wenigstens
fünf Prozent und höchstens 15 Prozent
des gezahlten Kaufpreises zu gewähren
doch geklärt sind die Fälle damit immer
noch nicht denn die Thermofenster können
im Ausnahmefall doch zulässig sein ob
das so ist müssen Gerichte nun für jeden
Motor Typ einzeln prüfen
zehntausende Verfahren sind anhängig die
Fahrzeughersteller geben sich weiterhin
kämpferisch ganz wichtig ist aber dass
der Anspruch eine unzulässige
abschalteinrichtung voraussetzt im Fall
Volkswagen gibt es keine unzulässige
abschalteinrichtung immerhin die
Richterinnen und Richter haben
klargestellt die Hersteller müssen
beweisen dass ihre Dieselmotoren
tatsächlich so sauber wie versprochen
sind doch der Streit zeigt im Autoland
Deutschland kommt für Diesel Käufer das
Recht nur langsam voran
und mit einem anderen Wirtschaftsthema
das viele Menschen hierzulande betrifft
geht es bei dir jetzt weiter heiß der
Mindestlohn in Deutschland soll zum
ersten Januar 2024 steigen um wie viel
das ist in der mindestlohnkommission
umstritten und sie hat daher zum ersten
Mal ihre Empfehlung nicht einvernehmlich
getroffen weil der realer aus welchem
Positionen heraus kam am Ende die
Empfehlung Zustande tatsächlich aus
Positionen die dieses Mal ziemlich weit
auseinander lagen seit es den
Mindestlohn gibt haben Arbeitnehmer und
Arbeitgebervertreter sich ja immer
irgendwie zusammengerauft und ein
gemeinsames Votum abgeliefert und dieses
Mal kam es zum Streit die Gewerkschaften
wurden überstimmt und sind empört nun
soll der Mindestlohn in zwei Schritten
steigen anfangen kommenden Jahres um 41
Cent auf
12,82 Euro dann ein Jahr später eine
Erhöhung von jeweils gut drei Prozent
also deutlich weniger wie dieses Jahr
endlich die Inflation betragen wird den
Gewerkschaften reicht das nicht für die
rund 6 Millionen mindestlohnbezieher sie
hatten mit den Sozialverbänden einen
Anstieg auf bis zu 14 Euro gefordert den
arbeitgebervertretern werfen sie vor bei
den finanziell schwächsten sparen zu
wollen
Wirtschaftsvertreter hingegen warnen
dass ein zu hoher Mindestlohn für viele
Unternehmen nicht zu stemmen sei auch
der DAX zeigt sich heute mit einem
mäßigen Start in die Woche denn das
Ifo-Institut spricht heute von
konjunkturellem Unwetter und warnt vor
einer längeren Rezession in Deutschland
auch deshalb hat sich die
mindestlohnkommission mit ihrer
Entscheidung so schwer getan noch nie
seit es sie gibt war die wirtschaftliche
Lage so durchwachsen
vielen dank
der Wechsel von Fußball Nationalspieler
Gündogan von Manchester City zum FC
Barcelona ist perfekt der spanische
Fußballmeister gab die Verpflichtung des
32-Jährigen heute bekannt
die deutsche Fußballnationalmannschaft
der Frauen bereitet sich im
Trainingslager in herzogenaura auf die
WM vor die in knapp vier Wochen beginnt
bei Medientag heute ging es neben dem
Sport auch um das verbesserte
Prämiensystem
die stattliche wenn auch immer noch
nicht gleicher Erhöhung der wm-prämien
durch die FIFA fand im deutschen
Trainingslager großen Zuspruch das sind
wir natürlich sehr sehr zufrieden dass
es auch so eine Entwicklung nimmt aber
für uns steht einfach das sportliche im
Vordergrund und umso schöner wenn es
dann dementsprechend auch mit premier
noch belohnt wird die Stimmung im
deutschen Team ist bestens und
entsprechend selbstbewusst heißt das
Team zur WM der Titel ganz klar also
nicht nur ich persönlich sondern auch
die Mannschaft an sich
fährt zu einem Turnier im Titel zu holen
der Teamgeist gehört für die
Bundestrainerin elementar auch zu jedem
Trainingslager und sie scheint mit ihrer
Mannschaft auf einem sehr guten Weg zu
sein
das war es von uns mit dem montagskino
geht es gleich weiter und um 23:50 Uhr
gibt es dann unsere heute Update mit
Nazan göktemia und sonst morgen wieder
auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter dieses Tief hier
auf unserer Wetterkarte das brachte die
teils kräftigen Gewitter im Norden und
im Osten Deutschlands da gab es sogar
Unwetter oder das Ganze zieht allmählich
ostwärts raus aus Deutschland und hier
im Südosten Ort das länger mit den
Gewittern dahinter kommt kältere Luft
rein ja und wir sehen uns hier auf
unserer Europakarte es ist relativ kühl
über Mitteleuropa 20 bis 25° deutlich
heißer über dem Süden Europas teilweise
30 35 in Spanien sogar bis 40 Grad der
Blick auf die Nacht letzten Gewitter
hier im Osten verabschieden sich und
auch im Süden es dauert ein bisschen
länger die verabschieden sich auch im
Norden gibt es einige Schauer sonst ist
es trocken Temperaturen sinken auf 9
Grad im hessischen Bergland und 16 Grad
in Bayern
morgen dann im Tagesverlauf neue schauen
und Gewitter die ziehen von Nordwesten
her durch einige von diesen Gewittern
sind dann auch mal kräftiger das ganze
schwenkt dann allmählich nach Süden und
dann ist es hauptsächlich Regen bis zum
Abend aber vorher gibt es viel
Sonnenschein vor allem im Südwesten
Deutschlands bei höchsten Temperaturen
von 20 Grad z.B entlang der Küsten und
27 Grad im Südwesten die nächsten Tage
gibt es weitere Schauer nur einige
wenige am Mittwoch bis 27 Grad und ab
Donnerstag nimmt die Gewitter Gefahr
wieder zu und die Temperaturen die
steigen wieder an damit ein schöner
Abend